joining us now is DePaul University
professor Jason Hill professor thank you
for coming on thank you so tell us your
view of why censorship from the left but
not exclusively from the left but mostly
has increased that doesn't seem like the
sign of confidence it seems like the
sign of people who believe they're
losing control well I think what has
happened is that the the right has lost
the cultural wars I think that we are
seeing a period since the 1964-65 period
in which the Free Speech Movement was
fought ironically by the far left the
far we are under the nefarious control
of a left far left movement that is in
cultural exercising cultural power and
is in control control of our cultural
institutions and what we have are these
institutions like Google like Twitter
like YouTube yielding to that cultural
power out of fear of retribution or
repercussions that they fear will have
financial consequences but make no
mistake about it we are in the throes of
a far left that has exercised and is
exercising great cultural power over our
society they have won the cultural wars
whatever understand is why people who
dissent who have different views tend to
be so passive in the face of attempts to
shut them up I understand why people
don't like Alex Jones I'm not defending
Alex Jones his views obviously but if
they can silence a radio show host or if
they can silence James Day more the
engineer at Google why can't they
silence you well why can't they silence
me of course they can
why don't we fight back against this we
we can't fight the fight back because we
have not have we don't have the moral
courage to fight the opposition we are
apologists for our values and we're
apologists for our principles yes we
have we have ceded the moral high ground
to the adversary
and in some sense we have given them the
moral authority out of some sense of
cowardice I think there's a great deal
of moral cowardice that's that that
conservatives have that people who are
even mildly conservative have and we
have ceded the moral high ground to
people who have co-opted values and
principles in the name of some sort of
morality that is nothing short of
nihilism cultural relativism and attack
on reason and an attack on rational
argumentation but it's a lack of
confidence a like yeah I think your
exact thing you're exactly right but if
all people who dissented from the
prevailing view of say are tech
billionaires who have so much control
over our speech paused and said you know
I'm not actually gonna go along with
this you don't have the moral high
ground over me and I am gonna say what I
think I'm gonna say it even louder if
you try and silence me I mean you could
actually make some headway fighting back
against it couldn't you you could but I
think people I think we what the point
I'd like to reiterate is that we don't
really realize the kind of cultural
power that is being exercised and the
kind of intimidation tactics that is
exercised and wielded over people who
have dissenting views there is a kind of
hijacking of one's moral conscience that
has to be reckoned with and I think
until people who hold conservative
values or people who are on the other
side of the spectrum say no this is
wrong free speech has got right he
defended and whether it's even I would
go as far Tucker as to say even hate
speech so long as it's not an incitement
to violence
I appreciate you sent professor for
reminding us of that thank you very much
for that thank you